la France et le Val de Loire victime
d'une série de fausses alertes à la
bombe ces derniers jours on en parlait
hier flan l'aéroport de tour mais aussi
deux collèges en Loiré cher victime
récente de ces actes de malveillance le
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald d'armanin
a promis de retrouver tout le monde à
propos de ces petits plaisantins qui
risque gros éclairage dans ce format
trois questions avec Marc Morin notre
consultant justice et réalisé par
Aurélie
Renault
nos services d'enquête ont la
possibilité souvent de retrouver les
adresses IP donc c'est important et
c'est des enquêtes qui sont relativement
faciles la difficulté c'est que
maintenant les hackeurs se trouvent
souvent à l'étranger et il leur suffit
d'adresser un mail pour désorganiser
totalement un aéroport donc ces gens-là
sont bien entendu impossibles à
interpeller et ils peuvent multiplier à
l'infini ces fausses alertes à la
[Musique]
bombe on constate que de plus en plus
les gens qui sont déférés devant la
justice sont condamnés à des peines de
prison ferme récemment il y a une
affaire dans le Nord où l'auteur d'une
fausse alerte à la bombe dans un hôpital
a été condamné à 6 mois ferme il y a une
autre affaire à hansy en Haute Savoie où
une femme qui avait elle aussi
déclencher une fausse alerte a été
condamné à 3 mois de prison
[Musique]
ferme il peut-être alloué par exemple à
un aéroport des sommes très importantes
puisque on fait payer à l' hauteur de la
fausse alerte à la bombe le préjudice
subi c'est-à-dire des retards d'avion
des des des préjudices enchaîne qui sont
généralement très
importants